وساده وغطاء وضوء للقراءه هذا كل ما
تحتاجه للنوم بهناء في الليل رغم ان
المكان الذي ستنام فيه غير اعتيادي فجرا
اكتضاض لندن بالسياح الذين قدموا لحضور
الاولمبياد لم تعد الفنادق المتواجده
كافيه لاستيعاب
الزوار غرف الفنادق محجوزه بالكامل وهم
يتقاضون اموالا طائله لليله واحده لذا
فكرت بتحويل سياره الاجره الى سرير في
الليل للاستفاده من
ذلك ويركن ديفيد سياره الاجره ليلا امام
منزله ويتقاضى على الليله الواحده 75
دولارا من
المستاجرين كانت كلفه هذا المشروع قليله
بالنسبه للسائق فهو يملك سياره الاجره
مسبقا والموقف مجاني لذا كل ما يحصل عليه
من الاموال هي بمثابه
ارباح ويامل ديفيد ان تعوض الارباح السقوط
المتوقع لدخل سائقي السيارات الاجره خلال
الاولمبياد اذا انه لا يسمح لهم باستخدام
الطرقات المخصصه للحدث العالمي الكبير مما
يزيد الشكوك بان السياح يتجنبون استخدام
سيارات الاجره لتفادي الطرقات المزدحمه
والتاخير وهذا دفع ديفيد للاستفاده من ذلك
الامر بطريقه مبتكره فقام بخلق هذا الفندق
الصغير وهو مريح فعلا الا ان مكان الموقف
غير اعتيادي وهو الامر الذي لا تستطيع
التفاوض فيه مع ديفيد واذا ما احتجت
فيجب عليك طب بيت ا بالفعل في سياره حتى
الان بينما حجز ارب مكان لهم في الايام
القادمه المكان هادئ وكانوا بغايه السرور
بعد تجربتهم النوم في السياره ورغم ان هذا
الفندق المبتكر ليس فاخرا الا انه يفي
بالغرض في ظل هذه
الظروف